on the eve of the New Hampshire primary
which is tonight Donald Trump did a
rally in New Hampshire and it was really
something to behold now we're going to
go through some of the the key moments
and for me at this point
you know the wacky part is less about
what Trump says although obviously Trump
is wacky and saying absolutely
ridiculous things it's more about the
supporters at this point who just nod
and clap along with whatever Donald
Trump says this rally was the epitome of
what I would call Trump culture where
facts don't matter
riling up a crowd with red meat that is
completely a dishonest if not factually
false is all that matters now to start
with as many of you know Donald Trump
has a very weird history about talking
about how he finds his daughter Ivanka
very attractive he's even said things
before like you know if she weren't my
daughter type of stuff and we've covered
that widely before and once again Donald
Trump talking about the beauty of his
daughter and he seems to recognize here
because he says I'm not supposed to say
that he seems to recognize that this is
something that is a little weird to be
saying again yesterday talking about
Ivanka and now clearly referencing the
fact that he said weird things about her
in the past take a look also a woman
that not too many people know very
powerful very smart very beautiful even
though I'm not allowed to say that
because she's my daughter Ivanka
[Music]
Trump then went as weird as that was
into his normal attacks on the media
claiming that they never show the crowd
at his rallies they only show his face
what's hilarious is as he started to say
that they were showing the crowd and
they continued to show the crowd during
this portion of the speech
they don't even like showing the crowd
they always show my face they never show
the crowd but you know what the people
can hear the crowd the people can hear
the crowd they know
the crowd of course visible at the start
and at the end of that 25 second clip
during which Trump says they never show
the crowd at my rallies and the crowd of
course just loves it and of course
that's more of the firing up of his base
against the media which unfortunately
has led to so much hostility against the
concept of a free press more than any
president in recent history Donald Trump
has really catalyzed in coalesced a
hatred if not disdain for media in the
United States under the guise often fake
news and we know the memes that he's
used Trump then goes on to talk about
how undocumented immigrants have no
addresses which is of course a strange
thing to say but more importantly he
seems confused between undocumented
immigrants and homeless people we have
video remember of Donald Trump being
confused between health insurance and
life insurance
that's a funny and depressing one we
have videos of Trump being confused
about many different things in this
video Trump seems confused about the
difference between an undocumented
immigrant and a person who is homeless
and then of course he throws in the
normal dehumanizing language that he
uses about immigrants record numbers
that we've ended catch-and-release you
know catchy releases you catch an
illegal alien by law you then take his
name and I just didn't have addresses
what's your address what they don't have
addresses they come into the country
they don't have addresses so you take
his name Trump then raises the lie that
he simply won't stop telling which is
that in 2016 buses full of Massachusetts
voters were sent up to New Hampshire to
vote illegally and that's the only
reason why Hillary Clinton ultimately
defeated Trump by 0.3 percent there it's
not because she really won it's because
Massachusetts voters voted illegally in
New Hampshire now of course there's no
evidence whatsoever for that claim but
if you're watching watch his audience
start to nod with Donald Trump about the
hundreds of buses of Massachusetts
voters sent up to vote illegally and if
you're listening you'll of course hear
the booing and the
audio of his supporters immediately just
falling for this hook line and sinker
because you know you have some pretty
strange election laws here right
remember last time we won the primary
tremendously we should have won the
election but that buses being shipped up
from Massachusetts hundreds and hundreds
of
and it was very very close even though
they did but this year we you know you
have a great governor look at how little
the truth is worth that Donald Trump
casually lies about hundreds of busses
understand what you hundreds of busses
right aside from there being no evidence
of this a lot of these polling places in
New Hampshire are tiny they would be
completely overwhelmed and paralyzed by
even ten busses showing up never mind
hundreds of buses being sent up to New
Hampshire but the crowd doesn't care
they clap and they boo and they nod
along to the lies that Donald Trump
tells and then again
riling up the crowd towards possible
violence Donald Trump pulls this entire
thing about we're going to protect your
guns they are going to take all of your
guns and all of your money and all of
your stuff take a look
we're gonna protect you second
amendments by the way they're going to
take away everything they're gonna take
away your wealth they're gonna take away
your guns they're gonna take away
everything
the cult of trumpism it's very dangerous
we wonder how do people believe this
stuff a guy himself potentially not
mentally well so easily is able to get a
stadium full of people to believe what
he says or even if they doubt it to
rationalize him saying it and this is
how cults work truly I mean more and
more it went when you look there are
more and more cult experts that are
looking at the cult of trumpism and it
is reminiscent in so many ways of the
you know the cult leader who says April
21st will be the rapture we will either
be struck down here on earth or ascends
to a life in eternity in heaven or
whatever and then April 21st comes and
goes and they rationalize it away with
trumpets either well the Democrats
ruined it or the fake news media ruined
it or Trump was using it as a metaphor
he didn't literally mean or whatever the
case may be it is scary stuff and this
is why I am afraid of violence I'm sort
of afraid of violence no matter what
happens in November of 2020 but of
course if Donald Trump ultimately loses
in claims that it was rigged I am very
worried about the real-world violence
that these folks are potentially going
to do let me know your thought on that
I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman we'll take a quick break and
be back after this some day we will
hopefully find out the truth about what
afflict Donald Trump and what is
responsible for his increasingly erratic
behavior and the speech trouble and the
memory trouble but for now all we have
are experts who are sounding the alarm
based on his publicly available behavior
and we've been talking about this for
years and slowly but surely the
discussion is moving more and more to
mainstream places we now have a series
of mental health professionals starting
with a psychologist from New York City a
Ben Michaelis who did an analysis of
Donald Trump's vocabulary over time and
what he found is that trumps vocabulary
has become more and more simple over
time with deteriorating sentence
structure and numerous experts believe
that this is indeed surprised a
sign of cognitive decline by the
President of the United States now some
are arguing well you know he's getting
to be in his mid-70s there might be some
a speech decline that would be
observable in anybody that age and that
sometimes does happened but again mental
health professionals saying that what
Trump is experiencing what he is
exhibiting exceeds just age-related
cognitive decline when you look at 80
plus year old attorney Alan Dershowitz I
don't agree with the word the guy says
lately but you see a drastic difference
in cognitive function when compared to
Donald Trump relative to both of their
baselines when you go and look at five
and ten year old videos of them a lot of
people seem to forget that Donald Trump
used to be very articulate the
psychologist Ben Michaelis says that
some deterioration in a 73 year old
would not be hugely surprising although
not a requirement by any means but that
what we are seeing exceeds that John
Montgomery is also a psychologist and
says that Trump must be tested so that
we can know what's going on and says
quote I think it's pretty safe to say
that Trump has had significant cognitive
decline over the years neuropsychologist
sterling Johnson says it could be
stress-related cognitive decline it
could be related to neurodegenerative
that's difficult to say
neurodegenerative disease or now I'm
thinking I've cognitive decline or
normal cognitive decline that comes with
aging we've talked about the slurring of
words we've talked about the dilated
pupils even in bright rooms with
professional stage lighting we've talked
about all of these instances and this
could be anything from a dementia type
decline to drug use to the side effects
of pharmaceutical medications to
anything in between
there's also notably the difference
between the two Trump's we've talked
before about upper Trump the guy
tweeting hundreds of times a day and
retweeting speaking quickly at events
with the rapid sniffing and then there's
downer Trump tired slurring low-energy
Trump very slowly reading the
teleprompter there's the miss stating P
apples names and words everything - from
you know Tim Apple - Marilyn Lockheed -
wanting the oranges of an investigation
sacrifice every day for the furniture
and future of their children
I hope they now go and take a look at
the origins for the oranges of the
investigation that we appreciate it very
much Tim Apple Maryland Lockheed Mike
Bolton as you know is in Russia Mike
downs justice 75 the Continental
Congress created a unified army army
Mandy a brand the ramparts it took over
the airports there's those shoulder
spasms that coincide with the mixed up
or mistaken words that we've observed a
shelter grandma - look look wait and let
me begin by wishing you a beautiful few
Democrats decided to shield and shelter
look look wait you have criminals all
right watching the president here in
Wildwood New Jersey I just wanna get a
quick comment before we toss it over to
Tucker Molly there's the times that his
tongue seems to sort of get in the way
of his teeth like in this example your
campaign of terror murder mayhem will
not be tolerated any longer it will one
more example of that to show you based
on the core principles of fairness and
reciprocity what
they can name it whatever they can name
it
peaches and God bless the imagination
these are episodes of some kind we just
don't know exactly what and you know we
need to be consistent we said Bernie
Sanders said he'd release his full
medical records I said earlier today he
should do it because he promised to do
it and we should know Donald Trump said
he would release his taxes and he hasn't
done it he should do it because he said
he would and Donald Trump should
actually be examined properly and fully
for what's going on here there's just
too many experts here everything from
urologists to mental health
professionals and everything in between
saying something is going on these are
clear consistent symptoms the cause we
don't know and it needs to be
investigated we had a beautiful sunny
Sunday here in the northeast of the
United States that includes Boston and
includes New York it includes Washington
DC and Donald Trump spent that sunny
Sunday exploding on Twitter and
continuing this morning there are some
interesting vocabulary analyses being
done of Donald Trump's speech and tweets
that show significant and continued
deterioration I'm not going to deal with
that today we're gonna deal with that
tomorrow the topic today is the
predicted predictable erratic escalation
of Donald Trump since being acquitted of
impeachment we knew it would happen and
it's happening we don't even have the
time to go through Donald Trump's tweets
individually here because there are so
many and they are so unhinged but let's
look at just some of them and I will
summarize others now understand that
Donald Trump spent the better part of
the last two days tweeting the president
has tweeted almost uninterruptedly
for the last two days aside from the
content of the tweets this is not normal
the targets included the fake news media
polling craze Democrats New York's
leaders the TV show Face the Nation Adam
Schiff Mitt Romney Joe Manchin Jerry
Nadler
a polling professional named Larry
Sabato and many many more Trump tweeting
about how he's we winning in New
Hampshire but the fake
newsmedia won't tell you that tweeting
about crazy Nancy Pelosi's impeachment
hoax which has lifted Republican
Congressional polls and my polls he says
way up which was expected but it has had
a great effect on Republican Senate
races including in a bunch of different
states thanks he says tweeting about the
crazed Dems
saying they will do anything honestly
and truth don't matter to them they are
badly wounded Iowa vote count was a
disaster for them then retweeting all
sorts of what I call adjectives and
dozens over a period of many hours then
going in on Republican senator Mitt
Romney the only Republican to vote
guilty and Trump's impeachment on either
article remember Romney voted guilty
just on article one not guilty on
article two trump saying Romney hurts
some very good Republican senators and
he was wrong about the impeachment hoax
no clue remember that MIT Romney is
reportedly now on Donald Trump's enemies
to get revenge on list told you about
that last week attacking Democratic
Senator Joe Manchin as quote they are
really mad at Senator Joe munchkin in
West Virginia it's actually kind of
funny he couldn't understand the
transcripts remember those were never
released Romney could but didn't want to
and then really ramping up the caps-lock
tweets remember as we've said before
went rumpus to defend Trump in my email
in live streams tweeting to me on my
Facebook page they engage caps lock and
turn off spellcheck and Donald Trump
doing the some of the same here starting
FBI director Christopher Rea just
admitted that the FISA warrants and
surveillance of my campaign were illegal
misspelled surveillance so was the fake
dossier caps lock therefore the whole
scam investigation the molar report and
everything else for three years was a
fixed hoax who pays the price and then
going into an almost completely
capitalized tweet to follow up this is
the biggest political crime in American
history capitalizing history by far caps
awk
simply put the party in power illegally
spied on my campaign both before and
after the
election in order to change or nullify
the results of the election it continued
on with the impeachment hoax terrible
and it continues then a couple of short
tweets drain the swamp all in caps make
America great again Keep America great
again in all caps and then as of this
recording Trump with a four tweet combo
today about the New Hampshire rally that
he has tonight going after aoc going
after Chuck Schumer going after the fake
news media and much more guys this isn't
normal no other president behave this
way there are two sides to this you can
look at the content of Donald Trump's
tweets which is absolutely unhinged
erratic and ridiculous but then you can
say forget about the content he's
tweeting sometimes hundreds of times in
a day tweets and retweets that alone he
could be tweeting about his deep
knowledge of philosophy and it would
still be weird for a president to be
tweeting this much other presidents did
stuff most days even if they did things
that we didn't like they were doing
things foreign leaders work on things
while Trump's attention spans seemingly
prevents him from having an in-depth
meeting without his attention drifting
to a TV showing Fox News in the back of
the room his briefings are down to a
single page to bullet points and a
picture based on reporting from inside
the White House and he is just tweeting
all day the one I don't even know to
call it a silver lining but the one
response that sometimes people have to
the endless erratic unhinged tweeting is
that if he's spending this much time
tweeting he's spending less time doing
things that damage the country that's
the one pseudo silver lining that
sometimes people find we're gonna have
more about this on the shows Instagram
page make sure you were following it at
David Pakman show and make sure you
follow me on Instagram at David Pakman I
posted a pretty pretty wacky
hate mail I got this morning on my
Instagram page at David Pakman alright
so we've been speculating for a while
that as Donald Trump continues to not
suffer consequences from different
events that take place during his
president
see he's going to become more and more
authoritarian the latest of course was
his acquittal in impeachment and we
anticipated that he would become even
more unhinged and authoritarian if
Donald Trump were to be reelected in
November he will become even more
authoritarian and unhinged and acting
unilaterally and why wouldn't he right
from the start of the Moller probe we
said this is not going to remove him and
Trump got out of it
yeah sure some of his friends went to
prison he's trying to reduce for how
long of course as we see with the Roger
stone case but why wouldn't he become
more authoritarian he got away with it
the 25th amendment many argue should be
used to remove a president that is
increasingly unfit temper mentally
cognitively to be President of the
United States doesn't matter it's not
going to remove Donald Trump we now saw
impeachment acquittal Trump getting away
with it once again so if you are Trump
why don't you do whatever you want
because they got they can't touch you it
really seems as though he is indeed
Teflon Don talking about pardons
possibly now we'll get to that a little
bit later
remember that Donald Trump so to give
you the the reminder Roger stone from
associate was convicted and the
recommendation from prosecutors was for
seven to nine years in prison Donald
Trump flipped out tweeted yesterday we
did a story about Trump's tweet which
subsequently was followed up by the
Justice Department backtracking and
saying well we no longer recommend seven
to nine years we just recommend some
prison time this immediately led to the
resignation of multiple prosecutors on
the case who were disgusted with the way
in which this was being handled and then
yesterday Donald Trump gave one of these
gongshow press conferences and there is
so much to look at here a lot of it
related to Donald Trump's incipient
authoritarianism the question asked of
Trump will you pardon Roger stone Trump
says I'm not ready to say yet but
there's lots of people who by the way
haven't been charged with any crimes who
in Trump's mind are
worse than stone listen to the specific
words Trump is using here and then we'll
discuss I don't want to say that yet but
I tell you what people were hurt
viciously and badly by these corrupt
people and I want to thank if you look
at what happened I want to thank the
Justice Department for seeing this this
horrible thing and I didn't speak to
them by the way just so you understand
they saw the horrible this of a nine
year sentence for doing nothing
you have murderers and drug addicts they
don't get nine years nine years for
doing something that nobody even can
define what he did the German buddy said
he put out a tweet and a tweet you based
it on that we have killers we have
murderers all over the place nothing
happens and then they put a man in jail
and destroy his life his family his wife
his children nine years in jail it's a
disgrace in the meantime Comey walks
around making book deals the people that
launched the scam investigation and what
they did is a disgrace or and hopefully
it'll be treated fairly everything else
would be treated so there is so much
here first of all notice that Trump said
I didn't talk to the Justice Department
now we don't know if that's true or not
Trump lies all the time he may have
spoken to the Justice Department he may
have spoken to the Justice Department
indirectly but Trump publicly tweeted
his displeasure with the recommendation
of seven to nine years in prison for
Roger stone the Justice Department is
monitoring Trump's tweets bill Barr
knows what it is that Donald Trump wants
so this idea that even if true is a mere
irrelevant technicality that Trump
didn't talk to the Justice Department he
slips that in there then Trump says
stone shouldn't get nine years in prison
because James Comey isn't in prison now
that's not an argument I believe most of
our audience would understand that it is
not a legal argument it is not an
ethical argument it's not an American
argument to say stone who's been
convicted shouldn't get nine years
because the FBI director Trump fired to
obstruct the Russia probe isn't
currently imprisoned Comey has not been
charged with anything never mind
convicted there is there are a few
things less American than suggesting
stone sentence should be lower because
someone who's not been even legally
formally accused of a crime is not
currently in prison then Trump was asked
and this is very interesting did you
learn a lesson from impeachment and
Trump says yeah I did Democrats are
absolutely terrible check it out the
Republicans have said they hope you
would learn a lesson from engagement
what lesson did you learn from the
Pietschmann that the Democrats are
crooked they've got a lot of crooked
things going that they're vicious that
they shouldn't have brought impeachment
and you had that bite all numbers are
ten points higher because of fake news
like NBC which reports the news very
inaccurately probably more inaccurately
than CNN if that's possible MSD MC and
your MS and if you take a look at NBC
now I think they're among the most
dishonest reporters of the news okay
thank you very much everybody
now this actually is logical again the
molar probe Trump gets out scot-free
believes it's an exoneration even though
it's not 25th amendment stuff isn't
going to touch him impeachment he gets
acquitted he's gotten away with
pardoning people what all of this stuff
right yeah what Trump learned from all
of these things including impeachment is
there's a lot of people trying to do
stuff to me they're failing I feel like
it's an exoneration
and they must be bad people because it's
all felt like a huge waste of time now
by the way this issue of continuing
through our tour of authoritarianism
through Donald Trump's mind despite
saying yesterday that he did not talk to
the Justice Department here he is in the
last couple of days saying if he wanted
to talk to the Justice Department and
tell them what to do about Roger stone
sentence he absolutely would have the
legal right to do it check it out I
thought it was ridiculous that yeah that
if that's no I didn't speak to the just
I'd be able to do it if I wanted I have
the absolute right to do it I stay out
of things to a degree that people
wouldn't believe but I didn't speak to
him I thought the recommendation was
ridiculous I thought the whole
prosecution was
and I look at others that haven't been
prosecuted or I don't know where it is
now but when you see that I thought it
was a himself to our country and again
he's probably right he probably would be
able to get away with that because he
gets away with everything and once again
comparing Roger stone to people not
indicted not prosecuted this is a
completely unamerican way to evaluate a
sentence someone not charged with a
crime is free so stone shouldn't get 7
to 9 years because he's on Trump's side
politically this is you know I try on
this program we don't want to be
hyperbolic but we don't want to
understate things either this is one of
the most fundamentally unamerican ideas
that we've heard from Donald Trump so
far and if allowed to continue for a
second term this is exactly the type of
thinking that escalated by being a
sitting duck
by feeling exonerated from the Muller
probe from impeachment so on and so
forth this can lead to a very I will say
an even more dangerous Donald Trump in
office which is why we have one recourse
we have one option we have one path to
his removal you all know what it is I
won't even say it but it takes place in
November make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on Instagram for more
coverage of this and other stories at
david pakman show and while you're on
Instagram follow me at David Pakman
there's a conservative judge who has had
enough of Donald Trump's
authoritarianism and flouting of
congressional oversight and authority
and has published an opinion absolutely
destroying the Trump administration and
this is you know this isn't one of those
cartoonish Trump stories this is a judge
a conservative judge Frank Easterbrook
who says what's going on completely goes
against the checks and balances and
separation of powers that our country
was designed to have now of course Frank
Easterbrook is going to be assailed as
some kind of liberal activist judge the
truth is
he's an activist judge he's a
conservative activist judge judge
easterbrook from the Seventh Circuit of
Appeals is a regular speaker for the
Federalist Society a conservative group
this is somebody that the late Supreme
Court Justice Antonin Scalia approved of
as a possible replacement for him on the
Supreme Court so this is a right-wing
judge that is saying what I am about to
tell you and what judge Easterbrook says
is that when William Barr declared that
a court decision in an immigration case
was incorrect and therefore the Justice
Department the administration can just
ignore it judge Easterbrook said this is
unacceptable this is a violation of the
separation of powers in the United
States this runs directly counter to
Marbury V Madison which established that
federal judges review the
constitutionality of what other branches
do not William bar the Attorney General
gets to say yeah I don't really like
what the court decided so we're gonna go
ahead and ignore it
judge Easterbrook wrote in his decision
quote we have never before encountered
defiance of a remand order and we hope
never to see it again members of the
board must count themselves lucky that
Baez Sanchez has not asked us to hold
them in contempt with all the
consequences that possibility entails
the judge is saying this is such an
incorrect action by the Justice
Department that if the plaintiff in this
case I'm sorry the the defendant no the
plaintiff yes if the plaintiff in this
case asked the court to hold the
administration in contempt that the
judge would have to seriously consider
that and the argument here is that when
Barr says no thanks to the decision he
is effectively challenging whether
Marbury V Madison is valid which
completely exceeds the scope of what the
Attorney General is actually able to do
and the situation is less cartoonish
than when Trump fires Comey to stop the
Russia investigation right that's a good
stream Lee cartoonish and
headline-grabbing action by the
president what the administration is
doing here
according to this conservative judge is
arguably just as disgusting and
potentially even more impactful in terms
of its implications because it goes to
some of the key issues that define how
then how the United States is supposed
to work does the executive branch get to
make law who gets to ignore court
decisions which effectively render the
entire federal appeals court process
moot irrelevant and powerless is there a
way is there a mechanism to hold the
executive accountable for violating
established law when they simply say nah
I don't like the law we think the law is
wrong we're going to ignore it
Republicans say that they're about law
and order and about checks and balances
and they claim almost to pray at the
Constitution as if it were a pseudo
sacred text so how do they stand aside
and allow William Barr to just pick and
choose which laws he wants to follow or
not follow the law only matters if it's
enforced and if you have valid
enforcement mechanisms and if the Trump
administration has proven anything
they've proven it's not clear that if an
administration is determined to just
ignore the law to ignore checks and
balances to have a president that just
says now we don't want to know Thanks
then we actually may not have the checks
and balances but we believe that we have
and there's a sick irony here and I
hesitate to even call it an irony
because you have a movement the american
right wing which says we need the Second
Amendment in case the government becomes
tyrannical and we have a government
that's becoming tyrannical right in
front of their faces they're ignoring
laws they don't like decided by federal
appeals courts that have the right to
determine the constitutionality of
actions by the other branches they have
an administration ignoring that and they
are silent dictators ignore courts or
control courts and Trump is ignoring the
courts and trying to control them look
at the Roger stone case and the Second
Amendment people who say we really need
guns in case this happens are now silent
and this gets us to
if the administration is willing to
ignore everything so far what is to stop
them from ignoring the election results
should the election not go in their
favor
I don't believe Trump can force his way
into a second term if he doesn't win but
he will question the results and if you
need proof
look at the 2016 election Trump won in
2016 electoral Eve and he's been arguing
that the results have been wrong for
three years at this point in time just
imagine if Donald Trump loses let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman quick break back after this there
are two amazing developments in the 2020
Democratic primary from the last 36
hours other than the fact that New
Hampshire voted and that Bernie Sanders
won the popular vote they're tying Pete
Budaj edge in terms of Delegates
revelation number one Bernie Sanders has
all of a sudden taken over the lead not
just in one national poll but in the
Real Clear Politics average of recent
polls that's number one we're gonna look
at some specific ones number two
we now have Michael Bloomberg polling
third nationally at 15 and 16 and even
in a very recent poll 17% these are
stunning numbers for Michael Bloomberg
we don't yet know how his numbers will
be affected by the horribly racist audio
uncovered by our friend Benjamin Dixon
over the last 48 hours so let's now look
at the latest polls Bernie Sanders in
first place in the latest Monmouth poll
the latest Quinnipiac poll and the
latest morning consult poll all
highlighted in red on the screen this is
a major reversal that's been building up
over the last six weeks now surpassing
Joe Biden more on that in a second and
then incredibly I mean really incredibly
Michael Bloomberg recently exposed
talking very racist ly about stop and
frisk in audio that was released by our
good friend Benjamin Dixon Bloomberg
polling in 16% in third place in the
hill poll 15% in third place in the
queen of Quinnipiac poll and there's
another poll that just came out an hour
which we don't yet have in front of us
where Bloomberg is polling 17% so this
now shifts the national race quite a bit
the latest national averages put Bernie
Sanders almost three full points ahead
of Joe Biden in the national averages
Michael Bloomberg has now surpassed not
just peak dude edge edge but also
Elizabeth Warren in the national
averages at thirteen point six two
Elizabeth Warren's 13 so I told you
weeks ago without passing value judgment
of Bloomberg remember I'm not a
Bloomberg supporter although I find his
ads triggering Donald Trump very funny I
believe that in the end Bloomberg is
going to end up third or maybe fourth in
delegates I think Biden is increasingly
out I believe Warren is increasingly out
Bloomberg is now third nationally
Warren's downfall continues Pete
continues to be solid we are going to
have several contenders here for some
time now as far as Michael Bloomberg
goes the question is 15% nationally is
great
16% nationally is great 17% nationally
is great he needs delegates where does
he start getting delegates because
thirteen point six percent nationally
average is lovely but there's a 15%
viability threshold in most of the
primaries so where is Michael Bloomberg
in Nevada we have no clue the latest
poll is very old where is Michael
Bloomberg in South Carolina nowhere 10
days ago he was polling one in South
Carolina that's okay in the sense that
he's betting on Super Tuesday so let's
now look at some Super Tuesday States in
California Bloomberg is polling four not
enough to get any delegates but where it
gets interesting for Bloomberg is that
in Texas he's polling 16 that would get
him a bunch of delegates in
Massachusetts there's no polling since
October we're not sure in Florida to
pick another state
Bloomberg is polling or was polling 17
at the end of January Florida and Texas
are big states 219 delegates in Florida
228 in Texas so just if Bloomberg can
eke out his six
dean percent in Texas and his 17% in
Florida
that's 73 delegates that's way more than
anyone has right now of course other
candidates will pick up delegates in
those states as well so understand that
this is a long game
I maintain Bloomberg will be a bigger
player than lots of people thought we
heard anecdotally during our New
Hampshire live stream yesterday that
some some callers whose friends or
family support Bloomberg were shown the
Bendixon audio the subtitled racist
audio of Michael Bloomberg and every
single one of them didn't care so in the
next week or so we will see whether the
bendix and audio release hurts Michael
Bloomberg
I predict that if it does it will not be
significant that's just it's not my
opinion of the audio the audio is
horrible it's my prediction of how
voters will react so I want to hear from
you what do you think is happening with
Michael Bloomberg will the establishment
Democratic Party Democratic support
shift to Michael Bloomberg if Biden
continues to fall and warren continues
to fall in concert with Budaj edge and
amy klobuchar sort of being bumped up
and picking up delegates where do you
see Bloomberg's role here I know a lot
of people in the audience don't like him
particularly after that disgusting audio
I'm with you my friends this is an
analysis of what is not what we would
like and I believe Bloomberg is going to
be a significantly bigger player than a
lot of people in my audience and around
the country are giving him credit for
let me know and make sure to give us a
like on Facebook at facebook.com slash
David Pakman show after the break
not very much Trump content on today's
show for those of you who don't like
Trump content almost none of it today so
far we will talk about Donald Trump
getting his friend Roger stone who he
barely knows a lighter prison sentence
and we will also do an analysis of
progressive regressive and proportional
taxes coming up after this short break
okay we are now going to look at an
example of the United States under
Donald Trump becoming reminiscent of
sort of a weird mishmash of George
Orwell's 1980
or an Aldous Huxley's brave new world
I've talked about the differences
between those two books and this example
is sort of a combination of the two vice
president Mike Pence is now defending
the deficits that Trump first said he
would eliminate and later pretended
weren't actually ballooning Mike Pence
now saying that the deficits are part of
the massive economic growth pet plan
that Donald Trump is running with in the
economy with this story we can
essentially agree never to talk about
debt and deficit again if we don't want
to because it is almost like satire
Saturday Night Live level defense of the
deficits that they say are terrible when
it's a Democratic president that they
said they would eliminate that they
claimed didn't explode under Trump even
though they did and now they are saying
right yeah well the deficit is up and
it's part of our plan and ultimately
it's all gonna work out here is Mike
Pence on CNBC making this case and we're
going to do this as another sort of
disinformation propaganda debunking
where we'll go bit by bit because
there's so much here that's important to
not allow yourself to be tricked with so
let's look at the first clip to start
with the economy certainly the numbers
are very strong and and that the
unemployment numbers in particular very
impressive
I wonder whether you feel though a
little bit of the gloss of that
impressiveness needs to be removed
because of the deficit that the size of
the deficit and the direction that it's
it's heading well we saw in the last
administration a doubling of the
national debt okay so we actually have
to stop it already this guy's sick this
guy's a sick liar did you notice the
bait and switch there pence was asked
about the deficit which has exploded
under Donald Trump and Mike Pence said
you know under Obama the debt doubled
this is a bait and switch and it only
works if you are an uninformed person on
this issue the deficit is the one-year
deficit or surplus for that year's
budget that adds to or takes away from
the national debt if you go into a year
with $100 in debt and run a ten dollar
deficit
your debt at the end of that second year
becomes a hundred and ten dollars if in
the next year you reduce the deficit to
eight dollars you've reduced the deficit
by 20% from ten dollars to eight dollars
but you've accumulated another eight
dollars in total debt meaning at the end
of year two you now have a hundred and
eighteen dollars in debt a president can
slow deficit growth or reverse it but
that can even still not pay off the debt
in four years or even eight years so
barackobama drastically slowed deficit
growth but of course if you have a
deficit at all the debt keeps
accumulating year over year pence was
asked about the deficit going up under
Donald Trump which it did and Pence says
the debt went up under Barack Obama he's
a sick liar let's continue a doubling of
the national debt but we also saw an
American economy that wasn't growing by
more than two percent it was the slowest
economic recovery since the Great
Depression okay so they claim again
Obama's recovery was a recovery but it
was a very slow recovery it wasn't
really a good one this is also a lie the
stock market during Barack Obama's first
three years performed better than the
stock market during Donald Trump's first
three years deficit growth slowed under
Obama deficit growth exploded under
Donald Trump job creation at the end of
Barack Obama's presidency was actually
stronger than what Trump has had so far
we're gonna deal with that on tomorrow
or Wednesdays programs so even more lies
let's continue because this continues to
build up to this idea that oh no the
deficits are just part of the growth
plan that we have and the President came
into office and he said first and
foremost we have to restore growth
that's how we will deal with the
long-term fiscal challenges facing our
country and deficits and debt are right
in line but it's first about getting
this economy moving again and we really
do believe the trajectory of this
economy we're going to end the next year
in the 3% range which is what President
Trump said back on the campaign trail in
2016 so now Mike Pence is claiming Trump
promised 3% GDP growth and the reason
that he's doing this
make no mistake is because they just got
the 2019 numbers and it was 2.9 percent
GDP growth so now pence says Trump
promised 3 this is a lie Trump promised
four five and even six percent GDP
growth during the campaign he promised
it after being in office check out just
one example of this get it going the way
I really want where we have GDP getting
up to four or five and even six percent
because I think that's possible if you
look back in your notes you'll say when
I say four percent people said that
would be years well it turns out that
I'm right because without the hurricanes
this last quarter we would have had four
percent Mike Pence is pretending that
Trump promised three and that they hit
it or almost hit that goal
it's lies lies lies Trump promised four
Trump promised five Trump promised six
so now we are finally getting to the
conclusion and you will notice that
pence doesn't even use the language
deficit and debt
he just keeps referring to fiscal
challenges and he says growth is how we
will deal with fiscal challenges he's
finally acknowledging the deficit
explosion without actually saying he's
acknowledging it and saying growth is
the plan deficit as a percentage of GDP
though has has ticked up each year of
this first term would you like to see it
as a focus for the second term if you
will want to change the direction of
that well I think the president's been
very clear and we've we've sharpened our
pencils on our budgets and we'll
continue to do that and in a second term
we'll continue to address those issues
but but president Trump really believes
that the real long-term solution to the
fiscal challenges in Washington DC is
making sure that the budget of every
American is growing and you know real
income after tax income for working
families is actually increased by five
thousand dollars a year in the last
three years and so the president's going
to stay focused on a growing American
economy and once we get this economy
rolling we're going to continue to hold
Congress to account and we're gonna work
real hard not just to get President
Donald Trump four more years in the
White House but we're going to make sure
that we have
Republican Senate and a Republican house
to keep America growing in to deal with
those long-term fiscal challenges so
look at this for decades Republicans say
the deficits terrible we've got to get a
surplus we've got to pay off the debt
we've got to cut everything and cut our
way out of debt Trump actually promises
to pay off the debt within eight years
only the most uninformed person would
buy that as a real possibility
unfortunately many of his voters were
uninformed and they bought it the
deficit explodes Trump says well the
growth that my tax cuts are going to
stimulate will reduce the deficit
doesn't happen does the tax cuts blows
up the deficit anyway the growth doesn't
happen they deny that the deficit has
exploded now they can't deny it anymore
so they say well this is all part of the
plan and the eventual growth that the
tax cuts are going to cause is going to
deal with it no economist worth worth
their weight in salt
never mind Gould believes that that's
going to happen they have lost the right
to ever talk about the debt and deficit
again Republicans in Washington care
about the deficit when the president is
a Democrat and they stopped caring two
seconds after a Republican is in the in
the Oval Office this has been happening
for a long time I believe it started
under under Reagan if not before and if
you look at this from a political
standpoint why would they stop I mean
it's it's completely inconsistent it's
complete hypocrisy but it doesn't hurt
them when it's useful to them to talk
about debt and deficit if a Democrat is
the president or if they want to claim
that they are going to pay this off or
pay that off then they just do it and
they get rewarded for it rewarded for it
electoral e then they blow up the
deficit and in some way they justified
and people are either too stupid or
willingly ignorant and they just go
along with it with Bush it was like well
listen you know we had to do this Iraq
war and that that was expensive we did
what do you mean we had to do it we went
after a country that had nothing to do
with 9/11 and had no WMDs that was the
what we had to do it what are you
talking about under Trump either you
deny it's happening as is increasingly
popular at least with my trumpet
followers they say now that the debts
the deficit is not up yet it is theirs
just find the reports that's public
information
or they say in the longer term in the
medium term the reasons that we have a
larger deficit now are going to create
all this growth and it'll all work out
which is just not happening it's been
years already and it's just not going to
happen why would they stop doing it when
it continues to be useful to them
electoral they won't stop doing